what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here today to watch the next
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania of course got my co-host John with
me join but Andrew the Gordon Andrew say hi to
everyone hi everyone Spider-Man reference to
see what we did there citizen king shirt shops
or edition.com real rejects exclusive anyway we
leave a like that helps out the video
all right let's see what new stuff is in
store today inside of movies that were
like right around the corner let's go
foreign you're an interesting man
Scotland I hear a king you're an Avenger
you have a daughter but you've lost a lot of time
like me make it a proposal here
we could help each other with that
yeah don't do it Scott damn
who are you I'm the man who can
give you the one thing you want
I can rewrite existence and shatter timelines wow
oh this could be awesome oh is that Morocco wow
he can give us a second chance he
looks like a big Corey stole him oh no
flying Stingray the way of quite easy for you
or everything you call a life will end this
looks epic yeah wow the biggest Ant-Man movie yet
oh the Ant-Man may not want
her to watch this we had a deal
he's gonna get his ass kicked
punch him in the face
POV I don't have to win I can do this
all day oh dang wow I'm sorry Cassie
oh
wow what an epic trailer glorious
that's a glorious trailer okay wow that's a
lot to digest right there there's so much to
digest right there I'm loving the setup of this
movie so far of Kane coming in being like hey
I'm actually a good guy I'm here to help you Scott
I can get you time back and then over the course
of time as this movie plays out discovering
no wait he's actually a terrible human being
he's got some devious plans at least the way
the trailer is going about it it would imply
that Janet definitely knew who Kane was already
and had experiences with King Parker she's like
not dumping a bunch of exposition but at least
explaining some stuff here and it looks like when
they get into the quantum realm that Scott and
Janet are separated from Scott Cassie you know
she's not there to warn them about King while
they're interacting with gang and it's sort of
building up to that before Scott learns the truth
about all this beyond that man there were just so
many like crazy visuals throughout it looks like
he's going to be exploring all different kinds of
scotlings and all different like the Multiverse
Contraptions would you call this multiversion the
quantum verse Contraptions but I thought this was
a a beautiful epic perilous trailer and and Kang
looks awesome this looks this looks really really
awesome and more of the Multiverse Saga that we've
been hoping and waiting for John what did you
think of Modoc and the giant Corey stole head
that's right I'm excited to see this ridiculous
character coming to live action on screen and
yeah I mean just the array of I mean not only
yeah King Ant-Man but the things that await in
the quantum realm that we are going to see more
of than we ever have before like this does feel
someone's gonna make that joke it's the smallest
movie but it also looks like one of the bigger
ones and I think that's really cool and I think
it also this looks intense and harrowing like this
looks like us this will hit the fields but in a
sort of desperate kind of way like I just get a
foreboding sense from this trailer and I love that
they're pitching Kang like a guy who is you know
who is not a villain villain he's clearly got a
plan and he wants to mutually benefit one another
but you're gonna come to that crossroads where the
ideology is too severe year and I can already feel
the emotional weight of the choices Scott's gonna
have to make it's cool to come out of an Ant-Man
trailer with the weight instead of just like oh
cool fun and games and size switching and stuff
you know that's all going to be there this looks
hardcore man this looks like we could be saying
goodbye to some people and I'm sad about it maybe
maybe I mean it looks like that uh he might have a
a bone to pick with Janet himself actually Andrew
what'd you think it was a interesting trailer I
think everyone's biggest question was where's
Bill Murray uh that's what everyone exactly
visually it looks really dazzling I remember an
Ant-Man and the WASP uh the second film I really
enjoyed the limited amount of time we got to spend
in the quantum realm so I'm really looking forward
to just a movie that's based around actually
being in the quantum realm and just from what
we've seen in the couple trailers we've gotten
looks really trippy looks acidy looks visually
uh intense also I gotta mention not to get into
DC here but that shot where King like just broke
uh ant-man's uh visor it really reminded me a lot
of the Dark Knight Rises where after Bane kind of
you know crashed the cow I was getting some Vibes
there just like he's about to take a major beating
obviously we could see visually but I think that
really intrigued me the most on top of seeing
uh Cassie and their stature uh was I really am
very curious to see Modoc from the origin of the
character in 1967's uh uh Tales of uh of suspense
uh or you uh got it you got it issue number 90
issue number 93. I thought it was you know the
characters are really compelling character and
then in modox 11 in 2007 we really got to see the
backstory in the origin I don't know if they're
gonna have time in this film to go into the origin
story of that character George tarlington although
it looks like maybe Darren cross is possibly being
the character now but looks exactly like it but
either way the character is really a compelling
character he's got an interesting backstory again
I don't know if they're gonna have time in
this film with all the moving Parts all the
characters and everything all the storylines that
are happening but I really hope at some point if
it's not in this film I hope at some point in the
MCU and modoc's Future appearances I do hope they
go into the backstory because again he's a very
emotionally invested character he's got a very
sympathetic backstory and I'm hoping you know the
general going audience who doesn't know Modoc very
well I'm hoping they get to see that done properly
on the big screen I think it'll be uh somewhere in
the middle here I'm sure yeah I imagine I'll go
Full Tilt I mean it looks like he's working for
King at first but at the same time I wonder if
they're gonna do some type of complexity uh issue
with him as like oh maybe I should be helping
them out especially if it is just the Darren
cross who's become Modoc and he might it's either
gonna be something where he really wants to get
back at Scott or he might have some type of change
of heart I'm not exactly sure what they'll do a
mode up but I'm surprised they gave us even just
the I always wanted him a couple of times here
in the trailer but to get those two glasses and I
think the other thing about it is the heart of the
movie will be between Cassie and Scott from what
it appears you know looks like that he's feeling
so much remorse and guilt over a you know from the
first Ant-Man movie you saw how he just wanted to
be a dad and he couldn't be a good had because he
was too busy being a criminal and then he then he
lost out on time with her uh with the with the
blip and all that and if I feel like that'll
be the ultimate wrap around with this movie of him
making some type of amends with her now that she's
all grown up and she's all smart and it seems like
he's doing his own career path while she's doing
her own Journey he's not even really involved
with and this mission that they go through this
life experience might bring some type of resolve
with them uh by the end of it all so I feel like
it's got a lot of heart it's called Quantum verse
therapy yeah that's what it is absolutely and then
we're probably gonna get a big explanation with
Janet too I I feel like they have a she's got to
have some type of history with hang here yeah
that seems like all the biggest implications
because that's also got to be not only do you have
the direct physical stakes and her warnings from
before but I can also see that as something that
maybe draws some kind of divide between the pims
and the Langs yeah in the process especially
because it seems like Scott is very inclined
to take the this deal and get that time back well
yeah I mean you're talking about desperate earlier
and it feels like not only is Scott desperate for
something what a great a great Primal feeling for
a king to prey on uh but also like Kang looks
desperate like he's been trapped here forever
yeah and he'll pray on this one sucker and get
my way out yeah man I'm a prisoner but yeah I'm
also looking forward to to stature like maybe how
she gets her powers possibly in the quantum realm
because as we saw in the second film Michelle
Pfeiffer's Janet van dime she has that healing
ability from the quantum realm where she's able
to heal ghost so I'm very curious to see is that
how she gets her powers as stature or is it going
to be more like in the comics where after spoiler
Scott Lang dies she you know she honors her
father and she takes like the pen particles and
that's how she gets her power there so I'm kind of
curious which way they're gonna go if she's going
to get it from the quantum she already has a suit
yeah yeah but I mean I'm just curious if she's
going to get some kind of a power though like Jana
van like outside of the suit yeah comfortably just
from the quantum realm so I'm kind of curious
to see what's going to happen there it's just
again just the it's visually dazzling what I'm
seeing from the quantum realm and to me I mean
I always like to go see an IMAX movie anyways but
like just from the quantum realm scenes like this
kind of Demands and I actually I saw Avatar in
3D on IMAX and they played the trailer for the
for the first one in 3D and it is IMAX formatted
and I was like oh this actually looks beautiful
and worth watching in 3D and yeah this looks um
you know what yeah I think for everyone who had
issues with phase four I'm getting a feeling
this is going to turn things around yeah
I'm really getting the feeling this is going to
turn some [__] around all right guys what did
you think about the trailer leave your thoughts
down below thank you Andrew for being here John
you did your part yep subscribe leave a
like and hey hey we'll catch you all soon
foreign